there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock I've read here we are
it's Friday night for us yeah so we're
sitting here having a drink
recording episode 139 yeah with a good
microphone again we finally got our good
microphone yeah we finally replaced her
well cuz we figured I mean the other one
still works but it's a little
intermittent I think it's it I think
it's the jack on there yeah I can fix it
we thought it was the cord but we tried
a bunch of different things out of them
I think I think it's the jack that we
just bought it just bought a new and I'm
at the fixed number because that one was
used when we bought it so I don't know
if somebody dropped it or whatever yeah
but you know we worked ok but now we
have a better one so hopefully the sound
is a lot better and that means I can
start recording some more audiobooks
again it's a good case today this is the
case that really they kind of based
poultrygeist on I think the timing of it
is very close so I'm not really sure I
mean I'd be shocked if if poltergeist
wasn't partially based on this because
it's very similar like what happened
yeah um but like I said it's it happened
like so close in time that I'm having a
hard time like wondering yeah how that
could have happened
they made a TV movie about this that we
saw um they also did an unsolved
mysteries I actually have the 200 of
recommend the unsolved mysteries yeah if
you want to it was a lot more concise
and a lot more credible I think then the
TV movie well the TV movie was a little
bit exaggerated and it was based on the
book and actually even like the families
that wrote the book said that the TV
movie wasn't all that accurate like it
had some kind of yeah some of this [ __ ]
was the same but it you know what I mean
it's weird because I had I had never
heard of this case there's not a huge
amount about it I mean other than yes
there's a book about it that was run by
you know one of the families that
experienced it you know yeah it was like
a little segment on unsolved mysteries
like back in the 90
I think yeah um and stuff like that but
and you know there was a TV movie in the
90s also but yeah other than that it's
not like a big famous case I only heard
of it because Steve Mira told me about
it yeah he said what was that case and I
think it was in Texas and he's like and
it was you know poltergeist was based on
it it's like you know they only moved
the headstones that kind of said he's
like that's where that idea came from
and I'm like no way I'd never heard of
that didn't know that it was based on a
true story
so eventually like then I kind of forgot
about it and then I think somebody in
the YouTube comments mentioned it and I
was like oh yeah that's right I wanted
to do a show about that because I think
a lot of people don't know about that
case and by chance my step grandad was
involved in the cemetery business in the
south and so you know yeah I can tell
you how them insights yeah I could tell
you how shady the cemetery business in
the South used to be and probably still
is
I feel like cemetary especially they're
especially low-income Cemetery yeah
which many times in the South especially
back to the dream Crow era was euphemism
for black cemeteries yeah and my
step-grandma father's side down in
Laurel Mississippi owned a black
Cemetery and this dude was a piece of
work no you [ __ ] stories about this guy
I might get into some stories about Bill
wall Mac okay like I know when southern
people say bless your heart
yeah I could tell you about yeah I'm not
religious in case you didn't time I was
12 they were already divorced and my dad
wasn't related to him he was this ex-con
my grandmother married you know after my
grandfather my real grandfather died I
never met it my real grandfather but
yeah and he he did he could cause a lot
of trouble he caused a lot of trouble it
was funny though looking back on it he
wasn't a real bad guy he was just he was
just a piece of work yeah that he was
growing that's it I say yeah all right
so yeah so that's our topic today's
sometimes called the black hole
curse the black hope horror that's what
the book is called so that's usually how
its referred to so we're gonna get into
that a little bit like I said may or may
not be what poltergeist is based on I
kind of suspect that it is but we'll get
into that in a minute I think they only
shout out that I had to do is that we
have a new patron named ginger so hi
thank you name and thank you very much
it's almost kind of like a stripper or a
porn star name like this cute name it is
yeah it is one of those like stripper
for name type of thing names ginger
you're crazy
that girl's crazy ginger Tiffany those
are crazy I was just gonna say Traci's
also the Stephanie's are crazy too
okay I agree with you on Stephanie's and
Tiffany's and Janet thanks most
Stephanie's I've met and then like in
more recent eras man Britney's Britney's
everybody Britney I'm not [ __ ] crazy
yeah yeah have you ever seen like so
every now and then like somebody I'll
post on like Facebook or Instagram or
something like that like one of those
[ __ ] lists of like crazy girl names I
have to admit I always look to see if
mine is on there yeah I'm not no
Jennifers that's been around forever not
crazy
yeah it's beer actually yeah when fin
fur that's that's what you call when you
say it with the original spelling is
what it look like it was now well it
could have been fur it comes from
Guinevere yeah it's like I don't know
how it was Swiss or Welsh I saw it
written and that's what it looked like
it said Gwen VIN fur I think you thought
I think I could show it to you I never
liked my name it's alright honestly I
always liked I don't mind being Jenny
but I don't really like Jennifer she got
mad when I called her Jennifer sometimes
but it's just to me out Jenny and
Jennifer are interchangeable
I think it's because well one because
when I was growing up I mean I was born
in 1972 that's was either a year or two
after that [ __ ] movie love story came
out were like and her character was
named Jennifer in it and every [ __ ]
person was named Jennifer that [ __ ]
year I was in high school my English
class which was tiny it was like only 17
people there were five [ __ ]
Jennifer's in that class everybody's
named Jennifer or Heather it's Jennifer
Heather and Brian's weird I don't ever
seem to run into anybody else named Tom
there aren't a lot of Tom's this should
be a common name but I never should be
but you know I can't think of a single
person growing up that I knew named Tom
or Thomas let's get to the ship isn't
that weird yeah yeah so okay we're
talking about the black Pope haunting
Black Oak curse whatever you want to
call it although I did note when I was
looking at Black Oak curse there is also
like a gothic clothing store with that
name really cuz it's black oak cursed
calm so you know if you want to check
out some of their stuff I just can't
kind of came across it by accident but
yeah like I said Steve Meyer I actually
kind of first turned me on to this case
and then I looked up two unsolved
mysteries we watched the TV movie that
was based on it was I think it was the
TV movies it's called grave secrets the
legacy of hilltop drive which was
actually not the name of the street then
watch how screwed yeah it's on a bunch
of people have it on YouTube and the
unsolved mysteries to it this is rad
because remember when we did the um you
know our our tribute to unsolved
mysteries and I was saying that they're
usually really good about pulling the
official episodes like off of YouTube
because a lot of people had them up
there like if but now they have their
own channel yes they got them all up
there so not all of them but they have
like a lot of them up there the Dennis
Farina ones the Robert Stack ones so
they were actually interrupted yeah so I
actually got to watch them like without
feeling bad about it yeah so being that
show that we did Fox News on online used
our show or for some reason gave a link
to our show maybe they tribute to that
maybe they've gone there it was a
shameful episode I don't think so they
came out where the they came out with a
story saying that on
mr. E's was coming back and yeni booting
and yeah and at the end of the story
they have the link to our show and
there's right there
yeah and it was a listener that pointed
that out to us so if you want to go but
I saw the one there was one that had one
of the updated ones that had Dennis
Farina that was the one of the ones that
I saw and the one that has black horror
also also has like the Black Dahlia case
and the fumbler bank robber from Florida
[ __ ] bank robber these two come in
two trips on everything which and that
was really funny he must been nervous
[ __ ] dork I guess they caught him in
the end all right so this happened in
the early 1980s and that's why I'm
wondering like if this is real like how
much of the basis of poltergeist because
poltergeist came out in 1982 yes so
supposedly this neighborhood it's
outside of Houston Texas it's like this
it they sometimes they say like the
subdivision but it's actually kind of a
big area big subdivision called Newport
in Crosby Texas and they're building
these houses and they're not like not
like in poltergeist but they're like
super big and fancier pretty just modest
normal-looking houses because I have a
picture of it I'll show it to you
because I have a picture of the exact
same house actually one of the exact
same houses that we're talking about but
so they build this neighborhood in the
late 1970s early 1980s now this couple
moves in in I guess 1982 although I
think the house they moved into it was
actually built in 1979 and a lot of the
sources I read said that they moved in
like when the house was new so I feel
like they might have moved in before
1982 but unsolved mystery said it was
1982 so what but the house was built in
1979
according to Zillow so same in June as
Judith Haney they move into this house
which is you know their big dream poem
blah-dee-blah
so they move into this house and then
they decide that they're going to dig a
swimming pool yeah in their backyard
this is where it gets interesting this
is where it gets kind of creepy yeah
they're trying to dig this dancing so
before they go to but I don't know if
they have like the backhoe there
whatever nobody at the time yeah but I
guess they did the word had got around
that they were digging a swimming pool
in the neighborhood and one day this
dude this old black man yes they don't
specify who this guy is and they were
convicted protecting his identity they
might have a sentence he's some way he
was in the know about this sanitary well
some of the old folks in the
neighborhood did know about it because
they did like a scene you want any
involvement or anything yet even the
information he was like I know you're
planning on putting I'm putting a pool
there don't pull their buddies if you
see this you look here and then look
here those little indentations are
graves yeah he says I was not here you
know you did not see me backs out and
come from from dune the guild steersman
I don't think that's really how it
happened but yeah so the Haney family
they said that they were you know when
they were thinking about digging the
pool this cut this guy turns up either
on their doorstep or he just walks into
their backyard and says hey don't dig
there because there's bodies those are
graves right there right right so they
pull out the backhoe I can't do in the
south well look at BAM backhoe
yeah well I mean I think at first you
know I've read like little excerpts I
haven't read the whole book that this
family wrote loud the black hip horror
but I've read like excerpts of stuff
that like the people said about it yeah
and they said well at first we kind of
thought it was a joke but then we were
like why would anybody joke about that
so then they got kind of curious so like
you said they get the backhoe and start
digging around like where this guy said
they saw some wood shards yeah this is
back that backhoe off putting it over
there and they went down there and got
it in with gun here by hand with some
shovels and started digging yeah what
did they find
two Pine boxes fine boxes was bones
bones yeah they're just like real soft
brittle bones because they could see the
hands and yeah yeah so it was graves
yeah there was it was two of them yeah
and they were even like
wedding rings and things like oh that
detail like creeps me out the most like
what you were digging in your [ __ ]
yard and there's [ __ ] skeletons like
they were all I mean from everything I
read they said when they dug him up like
as soon as they were exposed to air they
started like crumbling and stuff like
that I guess they hadn't really done me
that well they weren't in today weren't
like in sealed hide wood in pine box
right there was this regular cheap-ass
pine boxes
so the groundwater can get to all the
bugs can get to in decomposition happens
which if he asked me I first of all I
don't believe in burial when I died no
burn me up roman-style
me to cremate me I don't want any rotten
at images of me rotting with worms and
[ __ ] okay
ya know last thing you want to do don't
put me in one of them sealed coffins
yeah all that embalmed that embalming
and the clothes hell no I don't want any
I'll just I want to vanish I'm not there
anymore preserve anything you know I
don't understand that yeah I don't
really see the point of it either no it
doesn't make any sense to me it's it's
it's some kind of a tradition that
America and and I guess Europe you know
have is that we have to preserve these
bodies I think it's morbid
I think it's morbid as yes very morbid
it could you think about it yeah why I
want to keep it it comes off as very
1800s you know very Victorian well it's
almost kind of like oh we got to keep it
in case yeah this resurrection this
stuff this [ __ ] like taxidermy
you know I mean that's what it comes off
as I don't know just burn me out Roman
style
well that Darth Vader was also I thought
I always thought it's a lot more like
environmentally friendly to just like
you know burn yourself it just scattered
the ashes yeah it's just it's fine ya
know what I mean there's you don't like
to lay there and rot that's smeared and
I don't want anything it looks like me
you know I mean around with worms
evening you know I you know I I don't
blame you right it is like it is creepy
when you think about it right but if
even though if you're not going but
here's the deal though when you really
think about if you're not gonna be
cremated
yours if you're gonna be buried if you
choose
that okay don't embalm the person don't
put them in anything let's go back to
nature put them in a damp cardboard box
and let him go back to nature and a few
weeks later it'll be gone yeah Eliezer
yeah I can understand that I know that's
why we enter the lifecycle right yeah I
think that's much nicer yeah because
then you might like feed a tree or
something like that that's not a little
worms a little animal bacteria the
bacteria gets right yeah just like an ax
Lion King but yeah so they find they
ended up now at as you would you know
they call the coroner and the sheriff
and everything like that so they come
out there and like finish you know
digging up the site and they found 25
bone fragments that they just removed
from a male and a female like you said
they found wedding rings
they eventually determined that these
were a married couple obviously by the
name of Betty and Charlie Thomas now
these two had been they had died
probably sometime in the 1930s and been
buried there they were former slaves so
way back yeah yeah I don't know how old
they were I don't think I ever saw any
slaves so after this well they have free
people too but yeah well they sure they
had been freed but never freed right
yeah but well what happened that they
found out subsequently like after they
were like oh well held there are bodies
on yes land so then they did some
research ask some like old timers in the
area and they said oh yeah that piece of
land used to be something called like
the McKinney plantation the McKinney
family apparently hired freed slaves to
work on this farm and then when the
people that work for them died they gave
them like this plot of land to be their
cemetery you know what I mean and it was
called the Black Hope Cemetery now it
did have markers headstones at some
point you know it did have that I do
have a photograph that I think might be
that that was taken like a long time
yeah and you guys
you would think that if you put a
headstone there that that shit's eternal
ah nothing nothing is eternal and even
those headstones in time crumble away to
into Little Rock chips yeah and it
doesn't take long it doesn't take long
especially if it was a low-quality
headstone yeah it wasn't very thick you
know these did not look like yeah cuz
they made some of them that were only
about an inch thick those didn't last
well but how does they'd fall over from
the rain
yeah and then they'd end up getting
cracked because of people stamping on
them or just whatever and then as soon
as you get a crack in it it starts to
break up even smaller over time time
destroys everything it definitely yes
specially if it's now being up kept by
you know grounds keepers and gardeners
you know living cemeteries where that
are still making money are cared for
especially if they're near a city yeah
or if they're historical but forgotten
cemeteries fall apart very quickly
especially if it's a low cost yeah I
mean that's the thing it's it's sad but
yeah there's only so many I mean like
the this you know wasn't a big official
cemetery or nothing like that it was
just like this piece of land they said
hey you guys can bury your dead over
there you know put markers there and
stuff once all those people got old and
couldn't take care of their relatives
graves
yeah the relatives and then after
generations day all those people are
gone yeah they either die or move away
so this whole thing about trying to be
eternal or some kind of eternal monument
after your death oh [ __ ] no man you
dreaming you're dreaming you're no luck
I mean even the Pharaohs this [ __ ]
wasn't eternal you know you're lucky to
be to have a monument exist for a couple
hundred years there was a movie that we
watched called the loved one it's a
fantastic movie we're gonna do a review
you really should I love that from the
sixties it's got this hell it's about
the it's about the funeral industry and
they came up with a really good idea in
the movie that the only way to really be
eternally preserved is to put your ass
in orbit or send you out now that'd be
pretty damn near eternal if you want to
be a turn-on better go call a SpaceX
it's just up there
throw your ass out into deep space and
yeah you'll be out there forever but if
you're here on the planet Earth yeah
yeah elements gets you the elements in
time that's right it's a [ __ ] I'm just
telling only a matter of time yeah don't
even try it so I just want to be
cremated I mean you might as well like I
says I don't like to take up room
especially like I don't need to be here
anymore if I'm not you know my
personality is not in there after you
die 70 years later you're totally
forgotten the people that are related to
you are dead yeah nobody remembers you
yeah unless you're a famous [ __ ]
because even like famous B even people
that are famous like a hundred years ago
yeah they're all don remember yeah you
don't remember they are famous movie
stars it's only a few of Molly
you only have remember it so like I said
you know you're yeah really the people
that are if you want to be remembered
forever be a bad [ __ ] like
Genghis Khan or I was just gonna say the
Impaler I will be remembered forever no
yeah so being bad actually is more makes
you more yeah because like you know it's
every successive generation of people
like sad but that's just the way human
brains work we love negative [ __ ] yeah
why that is but yeah so like I said they
got a lot of this information from a guy
named Jasper Norton who was like an
older guy and he told him he's like yeah
there's bodies all around here he's like
when I was a teenager I worked as a
gravedigger and I you know dug a lot of
graves in this area so he's like pretty
much this whole neighborhood they
estimated there were probably about 60
graves in this area wasn't like a whole
it was like pretty much a single street
like a dozen houses or something like
that and that's the area over which they
think most of the cemetery was like
beneath now they they speculate that the
last burial at this particular the Black
Hope Cemetery was made in about 1939 and
then after that since it was a private
piece of land you know once the family
or whoever that had owned the land
previously you know once they all died
or left or sold the plot or whatever it
was eventually sold to
development company of real-estate
developer and they did just like in the
movie poltergeist they just said hey
well too much trouble to like move all
these dead people so let's just clear
the stones out and we'll build some
houses on top of it yeah which is not as
uncommon as people would think probably
not okay I'll tell you more about this
yeah I would think not now a lot of it
had to do with the fact that those
coffins were not a modern coffins yeah
like if they were just wood box yeah
burial like that doesn't last long so
right after a certain amount of time
contractors in the state and all the
sewing stuff wouldn't build on there
yeah that's what they would do because
droughts and groundwater and bacteria
bacteria ghost is back there's bacteria
in the earth that goes down miles yeah
people don't realize that they think
that there's nothing down there that you
could take a core sample some of these
core samples have cord down several
miles they've still found bacteria I'll
read this er everything is coated with
bacteria ever and all winds everywhere
and that [ __ ] eats and if you're dead it
eats you up sorry for anybody that has
OCD out there but yeah biomass of the
earth is mostly these little microbes
well yeah all right many many times over
many times over that's why I don't
really understand the paranoia about big
living creatures like us and other
things most of the Earth's biomass or
these little microbes yeah and they're
making around for everyone yeah that's
for sure but yeah so the Haney family
are the Haney the couples the couple
they felt so bad about essentially
desecrating these poor people's grapes I
think the wedding rings was like kind of
the topper because they were just like
Jesus Christ these were like two actual
people so they actually apparently went
to see if they could find relatives of
these dead people but could not find
them so they said oh okay
can we you know make a nice grave for
them like on the property you know we'll
make like a nice little resting place
for them which because they thought that
that was the Lee
they could do because they felt so bad
about desecrating their graves now
apparently after this happened this was
when all the paranormal shits started
going on so I guess that I guess that
the couple that was buried there did not
like the new gravesite they were like
they they just wish that you hadn't
bothered them in their old one yeah
now paranormal aspects and their
paranormal reports in this case I'm
going to skip ahead you know a lot of
the paranormal stuff that we do I don't
really give it a lot of weight yeah
there is only certain select cases that
sound you know legit to me you know
based on my experiences I do believe in
the paranormal for free any and newer
listeners you know I have experience as
myself with it but uh this particular
case sounds credible to me because
they're not making any super outlandish
claims not really and I heard the
witnesses tell their stories and and
yeah it sounds like they really did see
something and they had some bad [ __ ]
happen yeah
images or your buddy come not images
apparitions yeah
they don't really describe them they're
just kind of an amorphous blob which ii
correlate like shadowy yeah that was the
kind of stuff that i saw also things
like poltergeist type yeah a lot of it
was like toilets flushing poltergeist
and yeah weird kind of electrical kind
of disturbances with clocks and that was
the kind of stuff that my poltergeist
experience had do you know yeah and in
this particular case there because
that's several families there are young
kids they're around and you know around
the age of puberty which you see it
seems to be that you need that you need
them around to fuel this stuff you know
just based on my experience yeah yeah go
ahead so evidently what happened after
they reburied this couple um I believe
the first thing that happened now um
Samhain II actually worked the night
shift he didn't get home until like
after midnight so so judy was left by
herself Judith was left by herself a lot
of the time she
the first thing that happened was that
she had a clock in the bedroom and she's
like it started like glowing blue and
like sparks kind of shooting out of it
yeah which drew her attention to it and
then she noticed that it was unplugged
so there was some electrical anomalies
there some similar to that happened in
Mad Mountain poltergeist that was
involved yeah the blue haze yeah and
somebody did involved in it did
blow-dryer evidently ran for a little
bit after it was unplugged but then down
very slowly which just yeah was a
blow-dryer wasn't it like a it was a
couple razor like a no it was a
blow-dryer clipper thing there's a
blow-dryer I thought you told me it was
a clipper no it's a blow-dryer yeah so
she said that was the first thing that
she noticed was like this clock like
doing this weird electrical [ __ ] now she
also said to that either that day or the
next day she said she got out of the
shower and she heard like the sliding
glass door like opening and closing like
somebody had come in or gone out and she
thought that her husband had come home
early but then she went out there no one
was there she said she also heard what
she thought was her husband's voice
asking what are you doing and when she
went out there there was also no one
there so she saw like heard a voice that
sounded like him but no one was there
yeah one little girl said that the
toilet would flush and as the water
would go down she thought she could hear
voices and amongst themselves in there
that was that the I think that was at
the other house cuz there was another
house where [ __ ] happened as well she
could you slightly hear voice would
sound like voices coming from that that
creeped me out because that was the Red
Mountain a poltergeist movie so many
people might know why out creeped me out
but doesn't I thought I thought the
exact same thing that yeah yeah but they
so okay the next morning apparently
after all of that happened after she
he's the voice and everything so she
goes in the closet to get one of her
pairs of shoes like her favorite pair of
shoes the reenactment and I think the
movie should it was like just like a
pair of red pumps or something like that
so she goes in the closet they're not
there and she can't find them anywhere
so her and her husband are
like tear the house program where the
[ __ ] do these shoes go then they happen
to go outside and saw that the shoes
were just sitting there on top of the
new graves that they had dug for Betty
and Charlie that she were dead they were
just like sitting out there like someone
and then they realize and I'm not quite
sure how they knew this maybe they knew
this from that Jasper guy who knew a lot
of the people you know because he had
dug a lot of graves in the cemetery but
apparently the day that they found that
was Betty the dead woman that that was
her birthday so they thought that the
husband's ghost had like put the shoes
out there it's like a birthday present
or something I was like ooh that's
creepy that's not a rare know with
poltergeist phenomenon classically
poltergeist phenomena usually is
manifesting around a young kid going
through puberty and it's just a bunch of
moving objects and it doesn't really
have is a ghost-like phenomenon but it
doesn't seem to be under the control of
anything that's dead yeah it's just some
kind of invisible phenomena they call it
RSP K which is a recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis possibly and I believe
under the control of subconscious but in
this case there seems to be poltergeist
phenomena I think it's RSP K but it may
be maybe it's being hijacked device
either spirits of the dead or possibly
maybe the subconscious of the kids in
that area are kind of like bringing
their fears of the Dead to life yeah
because as soon as the bodies were found
I mean the Lydia the bodies are found
and then all of a sudden so you might
have some kids in there they're scared
or good are freaking out and they're
producing an artificial ghost I think
that's more likely than there could even
be a chance where because I think of
quantum mechanics and also the quantum
soul theory they're somehow their
subconscious minds are tapping in to the
Past and kind of acting out as if they
were spirits of the Dead yeah even with
the knowledge of the dead possibly like
they knew about the shoes they knew
about the you know I mean you
dates and stuff involved so I mean it's
all a theory well like I said I oh I'm
always gonna think like I'm very
skeptical of like pretty much all
paranormal stuff but if this did really
happen like that I think it's far more
likely that it happened like you said
are spk then this is actually the dead
people being like why did you know then
like getting all mad about or any new
listeners in the book that Jenny wrote
about my experience I also talked about
a near-death experience from a
motorcycle accident and also an
out-of-body experience that I had was a
spontaneous out-of-body experience a few
weeks before that I believe that when
you die you go it I believe in an
afterlife I believe it's a quantum type
afterlife
it is a heaven heaven like experience
most mostly depend on who you are
probably or what you're like but I think
once you cross over you no longer worry
about who you were in the past and
you're not interacting with this world
anymore I I think you probably could but
I just don't think it's I don't think
you would care to because it's a much
larger universe after you die you don't
care who you were yeah so I'm not a huge
believer in the concept of somebody
who's died coming back doing [ __ ] yeah
at least not a long term there's a
couple stories where a mother who's
recently died come back to help the
child at an accident scene yeah I can
understand that but somebody who's died
years and years before you know yeah why
would they dick around the chances of
them coming back and interacting with
the live and I think it's very unlikely
yeah because that based on all right
we're dead like why would you do that I
never understand I had my near-death
experience once I saw the other side per
se you know I'll talk we've done shows
about it you can go back to what was the
name of the show where I talked about in
detail out-of-body experience I'm not
holding a basket I'm not making you buy
the book or anything I'm just talking
about it you know because of time
constraints no I can't explain
anything but the chances of a person
coming back after seeing the afterlife
that you want to call I think they're
very slim it's like heroin it sucks you
in to a higher realm you can't really
resist it you would much rather be over
there than here and the the material
world is unimportant because you're like
it's like why the [ __ ] would you want to
go back to preschool and talk to
preschool kids about about blocks about
it's not the way that's the way it's
like you're all of a sudden you're in
this multiverse imagine a 3d Internet
where you can do anything you want to do
you know I mean where your mind controls
every your mind controls reality
directly at the reality that you
experience it's a higher dimension you
know I mean you don't want to come back
to this yeah now I'm kind of lying there
because I kind of see the light where
maybe after a time you may want to come
back and experience things again you
know me and a limited state maybe come
back as a person maybe come back as an
animal or something like that just to
experience in the way that you might
want to play a video game again yeah you
know what I mean like virtual really so
I can see that maybe you might
reincarnate yeah maybe I would like to
come back as a kitty
you can might but you might want to come
back as a eagle so you could experience
what it's like to fly that was kind of
how Debbie ray and certain elements of
fighting for survival
all right now I mean maybe you might
want to come back to some kind of
extraterrestrial being because he said
why should we limit ourselves to the
planet Earth it's gonna be a little
chugging life out on other planets
and I'm also I was also under the
impression through my NDE or near-death
experience that time was open to you so
maybe you could reincarnate in the past
there didn't seem to be I remember well
I didn't really see any kind I did I
don't remember seeing any kind of any
limitation any kind of limitations in
terms of what was now air anything
was now everything was happen so
everything was happening at once so you
could access reality at any time so you
say well I want to go back and be an
ancient Egyptian maybe you could do that
this seemed to be that that's what it
was but you know if you read the book or
go back and listen to the episode
out-of-body experiences for me it wasn't
very long that the effect you know that
I was going yeah so I wasn't able to
explore all the options I'm just telling
you what it seemed to be seem to be that
you could come back into this dimension
any place right anything you wanted it's
pretty much you know wide open yeah you
could pretty much just like right you
could maybe be reincarnated in the
future or in the past just depending on
what you want it that would be the only
thing cuz I would the only thing I don't
like I'm not really scared of dying or
anything like that I don't like the idea
of like I'm gonna miss out on [ __ ] like
you know what I mean like I hate the
idea of like man what if something super
[ __ ] cool happens or gets invented
like five years after I croak that would
suck so I always kind of like to think
that maybe if I could I just like to hop
like twenty years twenty years so just
to see what I missed
that's all the highest love to see
what's going on the highest levels of
the afterlife seem to be like a
singularity there wasn't much you could
do there because it was a singularity
ya know mountain and it was represented
to me is just a bunch of white light and
a whole bunch of joy and singing and
yeah I mean you couldn't do anything
there yeah it was a singularity yeah so
you could stay in it if you wanted but
you would probably want to come out of
there eventually
it sounds boring it was like going home
yeah anyway let's get back all right so
when we last left the black hope
haunting it was the shoes left on the
grave okay mm-hmm
now it should be noted that the Haney's
were not the only people on the street
to experience all of this weird
paranormal phenomena evidently there was
this other family the William
family that lived I believe right across
the street they also had some weird [ __ ]
happened there and so like a bunch of
neighbors had weird should happen in
their house just like electrical anomaly
stuff like you know the TV coming on or
going off by itself the garage door
opening and closing by itself just
sounds like basic poltergeist yeah
toilets flushing you know just weird
[ __ ] like like faucets coming on that
kind of stuff like we've had that kind
of [ __ ] happen here as well yeah so a
lot of people on the street had that
kind of stuff happened but the Williams
family they moved in around the same
time as the Haney's did now the first
thing this was Ben and gene Williams
were their names the first thing that
gene noticed was that even though she
was like really keen gardener she'd
always like you know had a garden where
she lived before and stuff like that so
she starts like planting you know
flowers and [ __ ] like that in her yard
she's like everything I planted there
died and she's like that had never
happened before so I didn't know what
was the matter so I thought that was a
little strange then they noticed that
like all these little sinkholes were
opening up in their yard and the
sinkholes looked like you know a little
6 foot rectangular kind of grave site
looking [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it's like it's like we would fill in the
holes and the next day they'd be back
again so it looked like these kind of
like like somebody had dug out like all
these little square like gravy it's in
their [ __ ] yard and they couldn't
figure out like they wouldn't go with
they kept filling them up and they would
get one kid woman so they also saw this
tree in their yard which again that's
another thing that reminded me the movie
poltergeist cuz the [ __ ] killer tree
that ate Robbie or whatever they see
this tree and it has now the reenactment
from from the TV movie I think showed it
as like a downward pointing arrow I'm
not sure if that's what it looked like I
think from what I read of what Jasper
Norton said and like what some other
people said in the area that it wasn't
actually an arrow it was actually like
two long marks you know like that like
just too long marks and it was
supposedly because this tree was
supposed to mark where this guy had
buried his two sisters like in the
cemetery and so he put like
two long marks there to mark that's
where my sisters are like you know what
I mean so this tree was in the Williams
yard and they thought the markings
looked weird because I guess they
obviously looked like someone had made
them they weren't like natural so and
later on they did find out the person
that it Doug said yeah I put that there
because that's where my sisters were so
the Williams also started experiencing
paranormal phenomena in their house they
started seeing like weird shadows like
flitting around in the house that they
couldn't really explain like it'd always
be out at the corner I like shadow of
like a person going along the wall they
started hearing people whispering like
weird conversations they started
smelling stuff in their house smelled
like you know death like a you know a
really yucky like putrid rotting kind of
smell in their house they also had a
granddaughter that was staying with them
I think that her name was Carly I think
her mom had like moved to well in the TV
movie the mom moved to like Germany or
something like that like with her
boyfriend it was like hey here have my
kid for a little while I'm off
gallivanting around Europe or whatever
so you know they were watching the kid I
don't know how accurate that is but
that's what they did then reenactment um
you know she reported you know have like
real cold pockets in the house like
you'd go
you'd walk through and this be like
freezing cold in the house [ __ ] like
that she said you always felt like real
oppressive like there was always
somebody in there with you or like
watching you she didn't like being in
there by herself you know toilets used
to flush on their own she was the one
that actually said when the toilets
flushed you would hear she's like you
didn't hear it when the toilet wasn't
flushing but when the toilet flushed you
would hear conversations like you
couldn't tell what they were saying but
you could tell that people were talking
that people were talking and they wanted
you to hear it she said that's what it
seemed like like they wanted you to know
they were there but you couldn't really
make out what they were saying she's
like and you could only hear it when the
toilet flush and it flushed like all the
time and apparently they called plumbers
and plumbers like we I well the flip
toilet can't flush well yeah yeah if you
know how flush toilet works
back of toilet there's nothing there
yeah nothing there you know that could
that could go wrong yeah you pull up on
it damn chained it flushes yeah yeah
it's all there is to it it's an
electrical problem yeah doesn't I mean
so it's like the toilet flushing in a
way is kind of like creepier yeah
electrical [ __ ] you could always kind of
you know write that off as oh maybe it's
a short or maybe it's something like
that but a toilet flushing that has to
physically be that little thing coming
up and pulling the little plunger out
yeah it's like opening a door turn in
doorknobs right equivalent of turning a
doorknob yeah way of putting it yeah
it's not just like an electrical sure
nothing like that no there has to be
somebody doing that yeah so yeah in a
way that's great how we doing on time
let's see we are at 42 you know it is
I'm cutting back we had yeah my blood
results came back man I had all kinds of
enzymes inside remember okay remember
last episode when we told you he's just
been to the VA and he had his like
little thing and he his blood pressure
is high so they're they're trying to
figure out like with the dosage of the
medication and yeah and he also had
blood work done and that came back
yesterday
yeah and they released this mostly
normal but mostly normal but your liver
enzymes who they said had some liver
enzymes in there it's not funny but so
Lindsay didn't say it was like super bad
doctors kind of said might wanna might
want back off kela so I'm gonna - I'm
gonna take it down to like only weekends
and we're doing the show yeah cuz I mean
it's before I was drinking every night
but not pretty long every night but yeah
we didn't get drunk every day but we
would like watch a movie and have a
drink yeah have a drink yes and never
life settled me down so I could fall
asleep because I'm very hyperactive I
got hyper vigilance he does he's very
he's not high-strung exactly but he's
always I'm always on guard yeah I mean
you're better
than you used to be I have to say
obviously the money you used yeah oh I
remember
hahaha did you ever mention that on the
show yeah I you know I get you know the
VA pays me I have a bunch I had PTSD
issues and [ __ ] yeah I mean I [ __ ]
just man I had forgotten all about the
biz yeah I used to see in my mind
screaming monkeys all the time you know
they were after me yeah yeah but it'll
be little flashes but I don't have
anymore
you used to have really bad nightmares
so yeah yeah I don't have anymore but he
you've calmed down a lot actually
so I think though I went through a lot
yeah yeah with your life you did yeah I
don't talk about all the show yeah we're
I can talk about me he did go through a
lot so but I have to say that from when
I first met you like whatever it was
like nine years ago probably now nine
ten years ago um you are a lot more
chill than use me you're still kind of
hyper like a lot more hyper than me cuz
I'm like I'm so laid back that I'm just
kind of like whatever but um you know
fighting for survival yeah he's very but
you are a lot more chill than used to be
I mean you used to have [ __ ]
nightmares he used to be like super
jumpy I never hurt you though no you
never did no I grabbed you a couple
times but you did but yeah you never did
anything bad like you know you never
like accidentally punch me the face
while you're sleeping or nothing like
that but you used to have a lot of
nightmares and you would like threats do
because it would always Blake wake me up
and she used to like talk in your sleep
like [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you guys dudes in
your sleep yeah you know you haven't
done that for a really long time
several several years yeah I used to
crap your wife throats in her sleep yeah
I grabbed my ex-wife and throat by the
throat you know it's me it's me Nick oh
okay sorry yeah cuz I you know I forgot
who it was yeah but like you mostly just
like thrashed around yeah and I would
hear you talking to people like [ __ ] you
yeah you used to have dreams about being
attacked and eaten alive by
taxa wild dogs that was another one you
know what's weird as I had a dream last
night about a zombie and like everybody
got actual wild dogs trying to kill them
you hear me though what else what else
they used to you used to bother me I
don't know I just remember the monkey
yeah she used to talk about that all the
swarms of those little bitty like
capuchin monkeys yeah there's team
always been screaming and yeah big big
yeah you'd see him yeah but yeah you've
been a lot better but it so in a way
like I kind of it kind of horrifies me
to think that what if you'd gone to the
VA back then and got like your blood
work your blood pressure done it's not
that bad now it's like it's you know
it's high but it's not that bad but yeah
yeah your liver enzymes I said the
doctors like ya might want to lay off
now a little bit so we decided that
we're just gonna do it on weekend exam
if I gained a few pounds around here
it's Friday I was bulking during that
time so now I'm gonna go to my cutting
phase yeah yeah like cut out some carbs
yeah we don't need that many carbs we're
just eating a lot of protein yeah well
yeah well get around to help you'll be
all right I need to lose about 10 pounds
you see his monitor and his blood
pressure every day and work yep you
gotta go back and check it out you'll be
all right all right so we're gonna take
a break now when we come back we will
talk a little bit more about the black
hope haunting and also this other [ __ ]
story that I found that also happened in
Texas about a similar kind of thing
about a cemetery that they didn't know
was there and you kind of wanted to talk
about some more of that - yeah yeah buds
in that area yeah about the cemetery
business yeah so we'll talk about that
in the second half we're gonna take a
break right now we've back it in just a
few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
you should come again oh there she is oh
oh what that what that why that side
don't go under the bridge I know you're
so sweet so sweet
oh no no what's up baking yeah okay you
seem in a bad mood this morning the
faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts buy
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format alright we are back
from the break yeah we got Pookie over
here tearing up boxes yeah Pookie just
came in here she's like oh look it's the
OL it's the new box for the you know for
the new Yeti microphone she's like I'm
gonna eat that that's right I'm talking
about you so alright so when we went to
the break we were talking about the
Williams family yeah who were the second
family who experienced hauntings on this
particular Street you know like I said
they heard the toilets flushing with the
conversation stuff like that they heard
the back door opening and closing when
no one was there they heard footsteps
all kind of stuff now at this point gene
is pretty much I mean her and her
granddaughter Carley they're like look
we know this is because of you know the
the grave yard in the area that they
didn't disclose so we really need to get
the hell out of here now her husband
just as they doing pretty much every
episode of a haunting says you know we
can't afford that you know all of our
money poured into this house you know
which is fair enough cuz
you know not everybody could afford to
move at the drop of back because it's
super expensive yeah so they're like
okay well maybe we should just stay here
and you know fight it now after they
decided that then been the husband a
parent he said that he came home from
like I said he worked in the night shift
and he comes home one night a little
past midnight and he's like in the
fridge or whatever and he's walking down
the hall and he sees these shadow
figures like going down the hallway like
he sees his shadows of people and he's
like what the [ __ ] and he's like follows
after them and then he sees one of the
figures standing at the end of the bed
like over his wife and it was like and
then it like jumped or like hovered over
her yeah the way they were showing it in
the in the reenactment is it look more
like kind of like something out of
predator one yeah like a shimmery wave
yeah which man that really reminds it
what I kind of what I saw in Mammoth
Mountain yeah
with there's no way to describe it you
know I mean it's like it doesn't look
that obvious you're not sure you're
seeing it you know when you see if it's
just yeah can off of it it's like you
know it's there but you can't see it
yeah you know cuz you good because when
you start talking about it and you get
like all you know hyped up about it yeah
sometimes should start seen it happen
yeah it's like you know it's there but
you can't see it yeah and it kind of
looks like a halo around an object or
maybe like in turn in the that one time
where I thought we felt like it was
watching us up from the corner of the
room
we knew there was something there but it
just kind of look like a ball yeah you
know I mean like a halo around something
round but you couldn't see it yeah
that's what it looked like so he saw
that he'd ovett it yeah it's like this
guy's some giant brass balls apparently
like in the John particular yeah an
interview with him inside he's like oh
no you know you're not messing with my
wife so he's like jumped through it yeah
like a go to protect her
cold and sticky which that checks out I
remember sticky stickies a weird with
yeah it was you we would kind of put our
hands through those things it would feel
cold and strange but not really sticky
clammy is maybe a better word no idea
sleeveless it was just kind of cold and
then after your hand went through it you
felt like you should have done that yeah
like oh yeah even though you couldn't
really feel anything it was there's some
kind of an energy there let me just put
it that way some kind of energy there
that and it's kind of like a kind of
like you put your hand through a cloud
of yeah there's no way to describe you
have to see it for yourself but I could
the way the guy was talking and looking
at him he looked a little too simple did
you make it something yeah we've seen
that kind of [ __ ] you know my family
seen that kind shot - it's weird yeah
well like I said none of the claims are
make your super outlanding knows a
little [ __ ] around right now it's just
like oh the toilets were flushing this
yeah feelings of being watched and yeah
look in that direction and you see kind
of like something there
yeah like did you like [ __ ] demons or
nothing like that they said they saw
shadows like flickering along the wall a
lot of it feelings and your senses being
tricked it's weird so now the Williams
family they said that what was that all
about
yeah climb of the country oh she's out
there tearing up the tree the the chairs
yeah that's her favorite thing that's we
call it the kiddie merry-go-round yes
yes underneath the chair and like goes
all the way upside down like yay like
pulling herself along with her claws
she's eternal
but yeah just jumbled Jim yeah yeah so
the Williams family now while they were
living in the house I don't think they
lived there for that long of a time but
while they were living there evidently
according to my sources I've read said
that six of their close relatives who
were diagnosed with like weird
forms of cancer and three of them died
and they attributed that to them living
in the house like it was some kind of
like curse it was like spreading
outwards um you know so I don't know if
that's the case but they definitely
believe they thought that that that was
causing it
now the other family that I talked about
earlier the Haney's at this point they
were also getting kind of sick of all
this paranormal [ __ ] happening in their
house so they said okay well all we can
do at this point
maybe we can sue the developers for not
disclosing that it has nothing to do
with the ghosts they were saying for not
disclosing that this was a cemetery
yeah and they lost their asses off well
the sad thing about this is that they
they took it to court and the first time
they took it to court they won they won
a settlement of one hundred and forty
two thousand dollars but then you know
the developers appealed and on appeal
the judge I don't know if is the same
judge or different one but he reversed
the decision and he said oh well the
developers couldn't be libeled that
libel they didn't know that the
graveyard was their blah-dee-blah
even though they probably did but so
they threw the verdict out and then the
Haney's ended up having to pay 50 grand
in [ __ ] court costs so they thought
they were gonna get 140 mm right yeah it
was early eighties they don't if I'm get
paid fifty thousand dollars so
essentially yeah they ended up losing
all that money they ended up losing
their house and you know so they were
like alright well they ended up having
to file for bankruptcy so fun times
so the problem too was that them the
other the other couple the Williams they
tried to sue as well now the developers
in their case said well we want proof
that there's a cemetery their problem
was that in Texas and made probably
other states too it's illegal to dig up
a graveyard
so they want proof that there's a
cemetery but it's technically illegal to
do your yard because it's
supposedly a cemetery even though the
developers are saying it's not a
cemetery conundrum it's a catch-22
that's what that is
so so they're like okay well we can't
dig it you dig it up to prove it's a
cemetery but we don't want to say you
know what I mean so it was like this
whole thing so there it stood now gene
Williams got so [ __ ] frustrated with
the whole situation as you would that
she was like you know what I'm just
gonna go dig up the [ __ ] alpha you
they want a body I'll find a body yeah
so she says I'm gonna go out there she's
like if she was you know an older woman
at the time she's like I'll dig just
like two hours a day or I dig till I get
worn out i'ma dig till I find a [ __ ]
body then we're gonna get some money out
of them so so the story goes she goes
out there and starts digging in the yard
like under the tree that had the marking
on it because she knew that there were
probably bodies there according to you
know some of the old timers in the area
who had dug the graves
she starts digging now apparently she
hadn't dug for very long before she
started feeling really ill so she said
why should go lay down now her daughter
Tina who was 30 at the time said well
you know I'll continue I'll keep digging
and stuff like that so Tina goes out
there and starts digging into the grave
but apparently a few minutes after Tina
started digging she started feeling sick
as well so she said I really have to go
lay down so she goes into the house and
lays on the couch and then she basically
I mean she got so bad she started saying
take care of my baby take care of my
baby and like her mom is like looking at
her and just like her eyes are just
going all glazed and [ __ ] they call 911
they take her in the ambulance station
paranal hospital she dies two days later
massive heart attack 30 years old yeah
so the Williams family are like okay
that was some paranormal [ __ ] right
there because she I mean you know from
everything I know she did kids in warmer
you can't deny health problems or
anything like that she dropped out of a
heart attack at 30 years old in this
case you can't deny it there were a lot
of witnesses who said that they saw
things actually people died in this case
and there were bodies found so there was
a cemetery there was a cemetery was a
cemetery there yeah I mean the fact that
the houses are still there
like I said um the house where I don't
know if it was the Williams house or the
Haney's house but I think its 8:03 pop
its way pop I was like poppet like a
voodoo poppet like a voodoo doll what's
a poppet it's like it's like a little
doll I mean maybe there's another I've
never heard it in any context other than
like a voodoo context you know what I
mean like it needs like a little doll
but that's uh you can see twas a
cemetery at one time sure it was called
a poppet yeah it might have been but
that's what the streets called now all
that marie laveau you know yeah yeah
from back in the day so that might
people I think all the street I have no
idea but that's what the street is
called like I said you can look up the
house I have a picture of it 8:03 pop
it's way Crosbie Texas it's you know you
can look on Google Earth there it is
I'm sure that the people if I guess
somebody lives here now because I looked
it up on Zillow just out of curiosity
like I said it was built in 1979
apparently somebody lives there now
because it's not on the market because I
saw um like I said there's not a huge
amount of information about this case
weirdly you'd think it would be because
I think like I said that this is kind of
where they got the idea for poltergeist
but I saw like a couple of paranormal
groups that just went there and did like
EVP sessions and [ __ ] like that which
you know people live in the house
they're probably just like over it at
this point you like get the [ __ ] out of
my yard or whatever but I think that the
most recent one was from like a year ago
and I don't think anyone was living
there then you know so I think somebody
has moved into it recently maybe but the
weird thing about it is that I was I
found this article like I said this was
on unsolved mysteries and [ __ ] and you
know before we go too far to the reason
I'm saying I'm not sure if this is what
inspired poltergeists like I said I'm
pretty sure that it must have been
because those very similar I mean you
know the tree that whole [ __ ] thing
yeah um oh the swimming pool and find
the bodies right that sounds like it um
so like I said
when I saw this on unsolved mysteries
they said they moved in in 1982 which
makes it makes me feel like oh we'll
probably not because poltergeist came
out in 1982 which means it was probably
filmed a year before that however when I
looked up the house on Zillow they said
it had been built on 1979 and I think
the families had moved in shortly after
they were built so with this they might
have moved in earlier and I should know
- that tobe Hooper who directed
poltergeist we did a review of older
guys check that out
tobe Hooper was actually from Texas so
he might have known about that Montori
it sounds plausible you know it didn't
really it doesn't really take that long
to make a movie true okay it doesn't
yeah you could do it a year easy because
it's it's just too similar yeah and it's
it's not a case where it's not a case
where the people moved into the house
and they saw the movie and they decided
oh we're gonna come out with this story
because evidently they came out with a
story like before that could have been
ever heard about this going down and
then quickly a movie about it yeah with
the help of Steven Spielberg yeah
although you know it's unclear who
actually directed well because Steven
Spielberg wanted to do more of a sci-fi
thing but he wanted to be Hooper to
direct it and then Toby was like can we
do more of a ghost story so maybe he had
this in mind but you know when he was
thinking about making the movie yeah
that cuz he was from there and he kind
of has that's the whole case pretty much
like I said there was an article that I
found from 2007 where they were
interviewing people who live in the
neighborhood now to see if there have
been any further paranormal activity now
the funny thing about it is that at the
beginning of this article they're all
sitting there saying yeah we've never
had anything weird happen or anything
like that but the more they like talk to
different people the more they talk to
them the weirder it is yeah like people
oh well now that you mention it like you
know our faucets do come on by
themselves that are so some of them that
have have reported like some minor we're
normal activity which I thought was very
funny because like it seemed like the
whole premise of the article was that Oh
thing happens now which seems really
weird since those other families like
moved out but I don't know I just
thought that was very funny and I some
things that I forgot to mention to you
like some other phenomena that was
reported when the Haney's and the
Williams were there was that they would
also smell coffee every morning at 5:00
a.m. like someone was making coffee and
yeah and it wasn't that it was like
coffee that's nice but also some people
reported some weird [ __ ] with like their
pets and stuff like their birds would
like pack their babies to death or like
the joke like cats would eat their
kittens likes weird [ __ ] like that so
that was some other kind of stuff that
was reported you know but it's just kind
of funny the way this article I don't
even remember where I got it from but
you know where it said we don't
experience anything but then some of
them actually did now again while I was
looking for this case we're looking for
more information about this case I came
across this article that was on cnn.com
and it was from July of 2018 now this
was from another neighborhood near
Houston Texas and this was this is a
plot of land that was owned by the Texas
School District and they were gonna
build like this new Technical Center
it's called sugar land it was a suburb
southwest of Houston they're gonna build
a new Technical Center on this piece of
land now evidently there was like this
local historian and he knew like a lot
about cemeteries in the area and he knew
that there had been other ones and that
you know the headstones have been
removed or they'd been forgotten so he
told the developers that were building
this Technical Center hey you know might
want to check that plot before you get
too far into it to see if there's like a
cemetery there because there's a lot of
cemeteries around here that are not
official or they're not designated so
they started looking around in this area
where they were building and sure enough
they found a cemetery that had so far 95
bodies and what they found out was that
this was yet another black cemetery now
these
or what they think these people were is
that they weren't slaves necessarily but
these were older than the black hope
cemetery ones they think this was
sometime between like the late 1800s and
like 1910 or something what's these
bodies this is Texas yeah this is not
far from the Black Hope Cemetery same
city you know it's just a few miles away
they think that what happened here was
that after slavery was abolished you
know the the economy in Texas kind of
took a downturn because they didn't have
all that free labor anymore so what they
started doing was that companies would
start essentially enslaving convicts
you know what I mean they would take
people from prisons and they would
basically sell them off to all these
companies that would put them put them
to work in the gates make them trustees
and like work them to death and not feed
them and stuff and so evidently there's
like all of these cemeteries that are
kind of unmarked they did put them in
boxes at least but they didn't like make
markers or anything like that so they
this is kind of these big mass graves of
like all these pine boxes and that's
what this was was they found this kind
of massive cemetery of all and they said
the the people in them they said all but
one of them were men aged between 14
years old and 70 years old
they said most of them they could tell
from the bones that they had been
malnourished also that they had been
worked pretty much to death these are
prisoners yeah yeah yeah um but like I
said some of them were kids like like 14
years old so a dolt back then that's
really it's kind of a modern concept
right yeah dole who does a modern car
back then you were 12 they're like all
right get married and get out of here go
get a job go work in the coal mine again
so they didn't have the teenager concept
back in the 18th I think I feel like
that was just like a thing that's a
fifth Maggie that's old 1950s it was
like a 1950's no such thing as a
teenager no it's like once you a certain
age that was just like you an adult yeah
well I guess good go back and look at
the photographs man people have [ __ ]
13 dressed like adults they treated him
like adults yeah they did
yeah yeah I just I feel like that's a
modern concept to do forget about it but
yeah so that was apparently there's more
of these cemeteries but that was the one
that has been found the most recently
last I heard there was 95 bodies there
may be more I'm not sure if they've
identified any of them because I didn't
see any more recent yeah articles about
it but I just kind of came across that
and I thought that was very interesting
snow like oh well Texas is just like
full of these undisclosed cemeteries and
you never know you might be digging
around your yard they were easy to make
my step granddad made one yeah you
wanted to talk about yes in Laurel
Mississippi this is back in the 60s must
been early 60s my dad told me all about
it this is my dad stepdad well after my
dad's dad died my real grand dad his mom
ended up him remarrying and married this
[ __ ] ex-con okay he was in there for
some shyster [ __ ] he was bill wall Mac
whose big dude he's like [ __ ] 6 foot
2 big tough guy
I knew him is see dad or see daddy
everybody called him see dad have a
[ __ ] nickname one of the cons that he
had going is that he leased a plot of
land I remember who he where he leased
it from him might have been might have
been to town the city Laurel Mississippi
yeah and got zoned for burial which back
in those days and in Laurel Mississippi
that's about like for garbage disposal
really you know [ __ ] if it's not you
know they had rich cemeteries near
towards the center of that town but that
was expensive land cheap land you know
that have been you know near the
outskirts of Laurel and he leased that
land out there and turned it into a
cemetery and that was for very low
income which meant black people back in
those days this Jim Crow era yeah
all right and I heard all these [ __ ]
stories my dad worked there as a
teenager as a gravedigger where his old
black guy he said that the tripping the
[ __ ] out that all black I'd go out there
and he talking all those dead people
y'all stay down in there we're only
gonna be here for a few minutes we're
gonna take it up and it will be bad I
hear this shit's gonna share my dad well
he's like making sure nobody cuts off
nobody gets on y'all just stay down in
there and not blame him yeah it was like
a shell man I'll be out of here yeah
what they would do you know his name
bill Womack that was was my step
grandfather's name they would bury
people down in there on credit he would
extend the credit yeah a lot of these
poor black families didn't have the
money to actually you know there was
like a a fee to be buried you know you
can't be there for free still is so I
had to pay monthly after the bodies were
buried yeah it's like a low rental plot
right like a rental thing that's [ __ ]
up well they had all these [ __ ] scams
going on you know I mean first of all my
dad was always nervous to dig a grave in
there you don't know me why is he
thought there was already one there no
they [ __ ] dead they [ __ ] buried
him so close together that why you were
digging the hole there was always this
[ __ ] risk that you would hit a coffin
and they would sometimes dig down like
that and all of a sudden the [ __ ]
wall would collapse in and a bunch of
coughing water would come down into the
hole that you were digging bones and
[ __ ] you know I mean he [ __ ] dive
about him in that bowl black dude
digging the flavor ah how they jump up
out of there to let all the water
[ __ ] he couldn't pay me enough to do
that it was nasty okay and then here's
the deal all right
some of these families that were [ __ ]
buried in Argyle buried in there on
credit yeah wouldn't make their bills
okay I can see where this is going so
bill my step granddad would [ __ ]
track them down the the surviving
relatives a who ordered this plot and
say y'all need to pay me I'm a diggin
I'm gonna dig him up put him right here
on your front doorstep [ __ ] we'll get
back with you you know there'd be all
these excuses so he's like all right and
he had this rigmarole that he put him
through because this is all shyster [ __ ]
you know man this is how you made money
back in Mississippi he'd get a coffin
okay I'm the same brandy they were
normally burying people and then there's
little [ __ ] like is it like pine box
like that right and [ __ ] tape they
take a bunch of mud and dirt and put
that all on in a coffin and put it on
the back of truck throw a tarp over it
and drive up to their house and throw
the tarp back so I'll put him on your
front lawn no hold up hold up hold up
man come up with the money cuz I thought
the body was in there yeah yeah it's
actually just an tee box
you thought I made it but that was how
they got the body out yeah yeah good
scam going but it never that that
cemetery was really only an operating
business for about it never really made
any profit I was gonna say that seems
that doesn't seem like a very sound
business man it was just one of these
scams that in that an ex-con and could
come up with to make money without
actually having to work without half
because and all the way but much money
no not and all the labor was subbed out
right to other people you didn't have to
manage that all you needed was a plot of
land on a show and you can go to the
city and find worthless land and
Mississippi burger and then you would
lease the land based upon the monthly
charges for the burial plots so you
didn't have to have any money in your
hand to get this done it didn't work it
only went out for about 10 years 10 15
years and that cemetery quieted up close
it up and it got reconquered by nature a
cherry so you and and my dad told me
where it was but I forgot it somewhere
in law and it was not in a it wasn't in
a a good place in an area there have
been develop this one in texture so
let's see
conceivably today a company could come
in there and go we want to buy this plot
of land and put houses on like
developers yeah and nowadays the the
city government would have no idea that
that was a cemetery at one time well
that's what I'm saying and like in this
particular article where they were
talking about the one that they found in
2018 when they were digging for the
technical school outside of Houston they
are estimating that across the state of
Texas that I'm just talking about the
state of Texas here they're estimating
that there are 50,000 cemeteries even
though only about 1,700 of them are like
officially recognized or like have
historic designation so that's a lot of
cemeteries that are not like earlier on
the record but like you said it's not
you can easily see how that would happen
yeah and the headstones that bill Womack
sold his mind must've really you know
we're cheap they're not there they're
wooden and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] lost
now he was basically caught he left the
family by the time I was like 11 or 12
he ran off with the neighbor the
neighbor's wife classy yeah he met my
dad nearly killed him my dad my dad was
about 14 one time and he hurt his mom
outside the window [ __ ] screaming to
help him he looked out the window and Oh
bill wall Mac was chasing my grandmother
around the park car the front in the
front door yeah in the front driveway
he's drunk chasing her around and she
was holding him off with a rake all
right I I forgot what it was about my
dad jumped up and rent my dad was about
14 he ran to his room and grabbed that
[ __ ] colt woodsman 22 gonna shoot
that mother oh yeah is it the woodsman
was like a 50 0 22 pistol big ol long
target pistol
yeah Southerners back in my dad's day
it's as kids owned guns they still owned
them as kids
so he got his damn colt woodsman and ran
out the front door and [ __ ] got in
between him and bill he started shooting
at the ground pop-up out near his feet
and held him off he drunk it out the
neighbors called the cops and the cops
showed up they hope they all bill off
although how bad would that have been if
your grandmother killed him with a rake
yeah even not too long after that
anymore I guess love is about 12 so it
was actually longer because I couldn't
remember my that was right before my dad
went to the to the Navy he said he had
to get out of there he woulda killed
that dude yeah yeah he was I'm ended up
meeting him later on a long time after
the divorce I've met him in a bar with a
visit to my dad one time I know how
random
yeah Who I am don't you and I said no
and he goes he was my name is Bill
Womack and I went man you might use my
grandad because yeah it was fun you know
just a big old dude you know normal guy
but yeah my dad was shooting at his feet
my dad got 14 he's [ __ ] dance and
he's baked my aunt Krista was about
tenth the time [ __ ] today yeah he's
back in the day I mean nobody went
nobody went to prison Beckham those days
they they hauled him off to the drunk
tank he was drunk yeah he wasn't
normally like that he was he was mad
over something that my grandmother did I
don't know what it was some stupid
something wasn't it that important
biscuits were burnt
no no it's I think had something to his
money or something that he owned she she
got rid of something that was hit I
don't remember his beer can collection
something like that my dad I'm on
[ __ ] shoot you you know do my dad's
do my dad's voice my dad was a little
bitty dude he was only like five my
dad's about five foot three and my
granddad was about five foot two yeah
but he could talk his way up in the in
skirt he got like two years pregnant but
um he was that high school you name is
Oliver
Bolivar Ross he's our little bitty Irish
monkeys Irish American monkey people
got progressively taller as each well as
the nutrition got better
yeah and just marry and tall girls
different unfortunately I'm not so they
put building damn drunk take and then
they let him out the next day and and my
grandmother didn't press any charges on
him and nobody pressed charges on
anybody but the neighbors called the
cops my dad was out there shooting at
him
the twelve and his feet yeah yeah I kind
of feel like that happened a lot babe
like my family's from they said well
half of its from the south it's from
Maryland but I feel like that was kind
of the thing back then it wouldn't take
me taste
well is it yet it was family stuff it's
like yeah I shot his eye out but you
know what do you want me to do nobody
like reported it you like yeah I had
that coming
yeah but yeah but that's give you some
background about how houses can end up
being built on top of those cemeteries
yeah I'm because that was a shady
business back in the day especially in
the south this is Texas yeah there was
some shady [ __ ]
you know the people that owned those
cemeteries yeah yes I mean and after -
after certain amount of time the
location of defunct cemeteries is kind
of forgotten well yeah how would you
know yeah if it's not there everybody
that knew about it is dead right except
that one dude that came up and says I
think there's there's graves right there
well because they were old enough that
they were matted they remembered right
like that one guy he's like look I was a
teenager and I dug a lot of those graves
like I knew those people yeah um you
know but like I said you can see now I'm
not absolving the property development
company I don't think it was I don't
know if it was like a poltergeist movie
situation where like the guy was
perfectly aware that there was a
graveyard there and he's just like yeah
let's just get rid of those headstones
and then we'll just like pretend this
never happened probably knew but they do
knows the job that's what I mean because
I feel like here's the thing even if you
didn't know from the outset that that
was a graveyard which in this situation
in the black
situation that is entirely possible
because it was not like I said it was
not an official quote-unquote cemetery
you know it it was just like on this
private piece of land that was probably
about 60 bodies buried there um and you
know yeah there were headstones but they
weren't like super expensive ones or
anything so if it if it happened that
the you know company bought it and it's
like well but you think when they
started digging for the foundations of
houses because they usually only bury
bodies like you know six feet deep right
yeah you would think when they dug the
foundations a lot of the foundations go
down that deep maybe not it would have
come across that guy knew that if you're
gonna dig a swim pool you're gonna hit
that [ __ ] toe well yeah that's why that
cake you murdered the house that said
hey no house foundation don't be alarmed
but there's gonna be bodies there when
you look a house foundation especially
if it's on flat land you're talking to
three feet yeah that's true I guess I
always kind of feel like it's not gonna
be pipes and there's gonna be yeah power
lines but that's not all that deep
because where we live is we live like
right by I for like the major they don't
know what I for wait don't know that
well that's why I was just going to
explain the major like east-west highway
in Central Florida goes from Daytona to
Tampa all the way across the state we
live probably just a mile or two from
that but where we live when we first
moved in here it was fairly rural like
it's gonna you know is a lot of like
horse farms nothing like that but just
in the seven years I think we've lived
here um you know they have built
neighborhoods all around like it's still
pretty royal it's still pretty there's
still trees there's like a county trail
like a Cajun bear occasional bears we
saw deers coming back from the deer
coming back from the movie last night
yeah um you know [ __ ] like that
armadillos bunnies there's a we see all
kind of wildlife but in 10 years that
won't be here yeah I feel like in a few
years this is just gonna be all built up
yeah but I I was gonna say they built
like a really big neighborhood right
behind there's like a county trail like
a you know just like a walking and
Viking trail and that goes all around
the county and then behind that they
built like this other really big
neighborhoods so every time we walked by
there we would see the construction yeah
and I feel like I feel like if there's
bodies there someone would have found
that [ __ ] while they were digging the
houses out so I kind of feel like the
people that were digging the houses out
in the company were maybe like let's
just let's just remember that and then
we'll just put the houses on top of it
and no one will ever know anything but
like you said when the Haney's decided
hey let's put in a swimming pool yeah
that's when the trouble occurred and as
I said just in the [ __ ] poltergeist
movie Jobeth Williams and those are real
[ __ ] bodies apparently one more thing
I wanted to say too was that when I used
to go because ice to be married to a
British guy many years ago and I used to
go back and forth to the UK all the time
and one time when we were over there my
ex-husband's
uncle took us to this place he drives us
out in [ __ ] remote Wales right and he
drives us up in the mountains in the
[ __ ] middle of the night and I think
he's gonna like take us out there
murderess cuz I don't know that dude
that one alright so that was the first
thing I thought I'm like oh this is like
the beginning of an unsolved mysteries
episode and then later they're low and
then and then we never found her bones
you know what I mean it was that kind of
thing okay but what he was showing us
was that there is out in the mountains
there is a little cemetery out there
called Kevin goal.i and it's a cholera
cemetery and it was from like I guess
like the mid-1800s like a whole bunch of
people died like in this village and
they like put them up there and the
creepy thing is there's no sign there's
no road to it there's no anything like
he goes like off-road he's like driving
in the road he's like oh it's over here
in the grass shoe and he's like driving
off the mountain and the [ __ ] grass
and there's like [ __ ] hills down here
I'm like oh my God we're gonna die holy
crap but then and it's the middle of the
night - so he's like driving and then
the headlights all of a sudden like pick
out like all these little [ __ ]
gravestones like sticking out of the
[ __ ] bed in the middle of nowhere and
it was like the creepiest thing ever I
wrote like a short story about it called
quarantine it's in one of my
short story books but that's pretty much
exactly how I haven't except for the end
where all the like monsters came out of
the thanked that I that didn't really
happen obviously but that that whole
experience of just like driving off-road
like the bounce of whales and seeing all
these little crepes it's like pop up all
this and was like super creepy but
that's just thinking of thinking about
this black hope thing like reminded me
of that but yeah okay so I think that'll
do it for our discussion of the black
hope curse black yeah matteri if you
want to know more go on that damn I
think it was Season 2 episode 3 unseen
haunted solve mysteries what's the guy's
name
just the other host Dave Dennis Farina
Dennis Farina yeah it's there on I think
it was on a Robert Stack one too but
they had because you remember like when
they did the Dennis Farina ones like
they repackaged a lot of the ones from
the early Robert Stack thank you because
I saw the rubber Fritz on that it's on
that episode is towards the end and it's
actually quite yeah it's like the last
case that's because there's like a Black
Dahlia there's some other case they've
got the witnesses there and everything
and I watched it and I was like man I
think those people are telling truth
they're not saying anything super
outlandish so no just uh and the bodies
were there so it's not like they made
that [ __ ] oh yeah it was several
different families and they were just
yeah Gordon because I mean those are the
two main families that reported stuff
but apparently there were like about 10
or 11 other families on the street that
also had like minor you know guys
activity happening in their house too
like after the whole after the bodies
yeah weird apparitions toilets flush and
objects moving yeah [ __ ] like that like
they never did look for any more bodies
because I guess like I said there was a
mysterious yes we're all dying cancer
yeah that creeped me out too like that
[ __ ] 30 year old girl like dying I
can't early or dying of a heart attack
like that was like super weird yeah so
and also like I said they made a TV
movie called grave secrets it's not
fantastic it's a TV movie you know what
I mean honey Duke was in it she played
like the mom poltergeist yeah and it's
funny because in the movie I think the
movie was made in the 92 I want to say
95
or something like that they made the
neighborhood look almost exactly like
the neighborhood from poltergeist even
though if you look at the real
neighborhood like on Google Earth it
doesn't look anything like that it looks
much more like you know late seventies
modest kind of new but it's not like
shitty lookin or anything but it's
doesn't look anything like we're taking
a look at mysteries episode yeah that's
a three Farina and grape secrets is the
name of the TV movie and that's on
YouTube as well a couple people have put
it up so you can go check it out if you
want to and that's kind of accurate even
though the family are like myths not
really like the book but whatever so you
can go check it out if you want alright
so we're gonna wrap up 100 episode 139
hope you enjoy the discussion and
remember if you like the show like share
subscribe on all your social media share
with all your friends and family also if
you'd like to financially support the
show would be much appreciated you can
go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little paypal button in
the sidebar where you can go if you want
to give a one-time donation that is also
much appreciated remember check out our
last movie review which was david
cronenberg's rabid which i just found
out was gonna be remade this year or so
I heard we'll see so we'll see how that
goes
I think the fly is gonna get remade too
again but you know what well I I felt
like I was mad about Suspiria getting
remade but then I ended up really liking
the remake so yes it was good the very
end there's castle oh it was well I
liked that they did something different
with it yeah if they're gonna do
something different with it then I don't
really have that much of a problem
they've been remaking [ __ ] since the
beginning of [ __ ] Hollywood so I'm
not worried about it and remember that
our regular episodes come out every
Tuesday we also have movie retrospective
usually older movies that comes out
every Friday and we also do 13 o'clock
matinee which is three new movies in the
theater that comes out every Sunday so
check them out if you haven't already
that'll do it for episode 139 we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]